uh so welcome everyone to the second
shulman
lecture in the humanities for
metaphysics meets cognitive science
today um
i'm super pleased to welcome um
philosophy's rock star
and that would be professor
david chalmers who is university
professor of philosophy and neuroscience
at nyu um
so dave is a philosopher but also did
his phd in philosophy and called new
science at indiana university with doug
hofstetter
and he also does a lot of collaborative
work with neuroscientists and uh
cognitive scientists so he fits right in
with our venue
so
um
i mean dave is a rock star partly just
well in all ways shall we say so his
work is obviously that way he's known
for um both i think advancing really
interesting
speculative
controversial new ideas um and also he
has um one of the things i love about
his work is he has an eye
for um understanding deep philosophical
questions and how to frame them both in
distinctive new ways and also um in ways
that kind of even like conventional
philosophers can grasp and understand
and engage with um he's
also looks like a rock star which i
really love he's got the hair and when i
first met dave he had even longer hair i
was an impressionable very stressed out
grad student in american philosophical
association meaning um dave was in what
was called back in the day uh the smoker
which is this horrible event which i
will go on with you later but for all of
us that were graduate students we're all
traumatized and dave one of the
outstanding things about him is that
he's incredibly like welcoming and
supportive of new people in the field
and and engages in really productive
conversations with him and he did that
for me and it was probably the first
time i'd ever had that happen and i felt
so welcomed that's my primary memory of
dave but that has continued i've known
him for a long time and he has always
been that way with me with other um
philosophers kind of who are kind of
getting into the field and also in with
obviously with more senior people and
people who are kind of full-on engaged
with all of the major topics in the area
so he's a really
a leader in all ways um
and i guess i will not keep going on but
i could um let's just um welcome dave
he's going to speak to us about the meta
problem of consciousness thank you
[Applause]
um well such a pleasure to uh
to be here with uh with old friends
and
new talking in this uh talking in this
uh the series
i'm going to be uh talking about well as
laurie mentioned i went to uh
my advisor
in graduate school in philosophy and
cognitive science
at indiana university about about 30
years ago now
was douglas hofstadter
i don't know how many of you have read
hofstadter's works like goodell
escherbach and so on but he was
particularly fond of
the meta
perspective to almost any problem i mean
there's this slogan which is sometimes
attributed to him anything you can do i
can do meta
he denies that it was uh that it was him
and there's actually a long trail of
interesting history for that very uh
that very slogan that i won't go into if
you go online actually you can find the
meme attributing this to a manual can't
which is not especially plausible but uh
um
but uh yeah so the the idea today was
okay to think about making progress on
the problem of consciousness maybe one
form of progress
can be achieved by going meta by jumping
out of the system going up a level and
that's going to be
what i'm going to try to explore
in what follows
okay
um
so when i was
in graduate school i went to a talk
where they told me that meta x
always means x about x
so metacognition
cognition about cognition
a meta theory it's a theory about the
theory okay of course we immediately
said about finding counter examples and
okay metaphysics
is that physics about physics no not
really
uh meta ethics is that ethics about
ethics no not really but this one
actually fits the temp the template the
matter problem of consciousness is
so cold because it's a problem about a
problem
and the meta problem of consciousness as
i understand it is to explain
why we think and say
that there's a problem of consciousness
my thought is that's a distinctive
approach
to the problem of consciousness that
might itself be productive
and interesting i've been told i need to
go exactly 45 minutes so uh let me make
sure i've got my
timer in hand very good
um laurie is fully authorized to cut me
off at 45 minutes and zero seconds
i need that stopwatch for the second
hand now but
um
okay so
the meta problem is a problem about a
problem that presupposes first order
problem about consciousness and in this
context that problem is the so-called
hard problem
of consciousness
um so i think we said i was going to
take my uh
take my mask off right if that's uh i
gather the conventions for
speakers to remove the mask and audience
to keep it on if anybody is
uncomfortable and before i put it back
on just let me know
the hard problem of consciousness is the
problem of explaining
why and how
physical processes give rise to
conscious
experience
here
um okay here's an illustration of the
hard problem which i quite like
because it's uh somehow illustrates
consciousness as someone's hair catching
fire
this is maybe some kind of illustration
of the you know the the magic of a
conscious
experience but the hard problem is
concerned with what philosophers often
call phenomenal
consciousness which is basically tied to
what it's like to be
a subject
so um
you know this uh locution goes back at
least
to a famous paper by my nyu colleague
tom nagel in 1974 he wrote what is it
like to be a bat
and the thought was although you know we
don't know what it's like to be about
say engaging in sonar is it more like
vision is it more like
hearing but presumably there's something
it's like to be a bat a bat has
subjective experience just as there's
something it's like to be me there's
something it's like to be you we assume
something it's like to be about
most people would say nothing it's like
to be say
a cup or a water bottle
there's something that's like to be a
system you know roughly when it has some
kind of subjective
experience so we say a system is
phenomenally conscious if there's
something it's like to be it
a mental state
is phenomenally conscious
if there's something it's like to be in
that state so states
of phenomenal consciousness include
visual experiences like the experience
of color and depth there's something
it's like to have those experiences
other sensory experiences lack of sound
or taste
bodily sensations like pain or orgasm
mental imagery
like recalled visual images from your
childhood
emotional experiences like happiness or
anger
or indeed a stream of a current thought
like reflection and decision all
sometimes thought of as elements of this
rich inner movie of consciousness states
that feel like something to the subject
the hard the word the locution the hard
problem is meant to contrast with
other problems
of consciousness and of cognition
more generally
the so-called easy problems which aren't
easy in any absolute sense they're as
hard as any problem in science but
they're called the easy problem because
we've got some
at least better grip on how to go about
explaining them these are basically
problems of explaining
uh behavioral or cognitive functions
like say
perceptual discrimination
the integration of information in the
brain
the control of behavior
and indeed verbal reports like saying
i see that object
now these are all you know relatively
objective features
of the human system
we have a fairly standard paradigm for
explaining them
in cognitive science
roughly we handle the easy problems
these problems of explaining behavioral
or cognitive functions by finding a
neural
or computational mechanism that performs
the relevant function
maybe a neural system maybe some kind of
algorithmic mechanism but once you've
explained how it is that that function
is performed you've explained
you've explained the problem
but for the hard problem of
consciousness distinctively it looks
like explaining all those objective
behavioral cognitive functions
seems to always leave open a further
question
why is all that accompanied by
experience
why is there something it's like to
undergo those processes you know why
doesn't all that processing go on
in the dark
without consciousness as it might and
say i don't know a robot or a zombie
this seems to be what philosophers call
an explanatory gap here between physical
processes
and subjective
experience
so that's the uh that's the hard problem
uh here's a
illustration of something very strange
happening in the vicinity of the brain
and consciousness that we're trying to
get to the
the bottom of in solving the hard
problem
and there are many different approaches
to the uh to the heart problem in both
coming both from the side of metaphysics
and philosophy or from the side of the
science of consciousness i mean there
are approaches that take
consciousness to be irreducible
in nature and this is actually the side
which i have somewhat more sympathy for
that i've argued myself in some earlier
work that consciousness could be
fundamental and irreducible in the same
way that space and time and
and mass are often taken to be
this leads you to views like dualism
consciousness is distinct
from any physical properties but is
somehow an interaction with them
or panpsychism that there's some element
of consciousness at the base of all
physical systems
um or even idealism that the whole world
is itself a construct of
consciousness so okay so that's one set
of options
another set of options is that
consciousness is
reducible
perhaps to some kind of computational or
functional process
as
popular functionalist views hold
perhaps to something really
distinctively biological
that's biological materialism some
people have even speculated maybe
there's something essentially quantum
mechanical about consciousness we can
reduce it to some kind of quantum
materialism and there's been a big
debate about these
about these these options here in both
the metaphysics and
the science of consciousness but here
i'm not going to be concerned with
either of those instead i'm going to be
taking a third
approach the third approach is to do
what yeah what douglas hofstadter called
jumping out of the system and going meta
so instead of trying to solve the
problem we ask instead why is it that we
think
that consciousness poses
a problem and when you ask the question
in this way i think it just gives you
just a different angle on the problem
that comes with all kinds of promising
new directions
one way to uh to get at this
is to look at various behavioral
functions that are closely related to
the hard problem
with hard problems about experience not
about behavior but there are
behavioral functions
that are very closely connected not
least that we make what i'll call
phenomenal reports
or reports of conscious experience oh
dear i hope that's not ominous
uh yeah perfect um okay so yeah these um
objective function which is closely
related to consciousness is the
existence of phenomenal reports or
verbal reports of conscious experiences
people say things like
i am conscious there's something it's
like to be me i am feeling pain now
and so on and although consciousness
itself may be a hard problem looks like
these reports are in the vicinity of
objective functions potentially
explicable by the standard mechanisms of
cognitive science so in principle
explaining those falls under the
category of the easy problems
oh sorry next one
then we also have what i call
problem reports
which are you know reports that
consciousness seems like peculiarly
mysterious or difficult
to
explain sorry we go back one to the one
that says problem reports
perfect um reports expressing our sense
that consciousness poses
a hard problem maybe it's a slightly
smaller group now but there are at least
some people
out there who say things like boy it's
really disturbing seeing yourself
like that from the side
yeah right yeah
super meta self-consciousness upon
self-consciousness and who is that
zombie david chalmers who's
underneath
that's really worrying
there is a hard problem of consciousness
say people say things like explaining
behavior
doesn't explain consciousness
um
fantastic thanks sorry about that
uh consciousness seems non-physical and
so on again those things are behaviors
in principle open to
paradigmatic cognitive science
explanation so the meta problem of
consciousness as i understand it is
basically the problem of explaining
those problem reports
in principle possible about behavior so
it's an easy problem ought to be open to
standard kinds of functional
explanation
so the meta problem is an easy problem
but it's closely tied to the hard
problem in some ways it looks more
tractable than the hard problem and
solving it ultimately shed some light on
the hard problem if you like this is a
kind of potentially what people call a
genealogical approach to you know to
philosophical problems we don't exactly
try and solve the problem directly but
we look at you know why it is that this
problem exists in the first place
sometimes people do this by focusing on
cultural
uh
on cultural history or maybe some kind
of evolutionary history for example you
know you might take this some people
take this approach to to god instead of
trying to figure out is there a god
figure out why do we think there's a god
in the first place
sometimes if you find some evolutionary
or cultural
explanation of why we think there's a
god some people then think okay that
actually debunks the existence of god we
no longer have strong reason to believe
um in god after we've explained why we
have these beliefs that much is
controversial but it's quite common
um to take this line about consciousness
and at least in recent years a few
people
have uh have taken it and this leads to
the view
sometimes called illusionism
that consciousness or at least the
problem of consciousness
is an
illusion we believe that there are these
special we have these special properties
that pose a problem
but we don't really explain why we have
those beliefs
and we might dissolve the problem so
that's to say that solving the meta
problem
could dissolve
the hard problem
and in recent years that's actually
become quite a popular view this started
to receive some systematic attention
here's a
a book that focused on uh
on a central paper by keith frankish
called illusionism as the theory of
consciousness yeah depicting the
mind-body problem as some kind of magic
trick we all seem to ourselves to have
these magical properties that in fact
we don't in fact illusionism has a long
history
uh in philosophy so immanuel kant
in the critique of pure reason talked
about some elements of the unity of self
as a transcendental
illusion uh
the materialist philosopher ut place who
identified mental states for the brain
states said yeah we have this sense
there's something more
but he said it was a kind of
phenomenological fallacy
um another australian philosopher david
armstrong talked about a distinctive
kind of
illusion tied to a circus illusion
called the the headless woman illusion
i'll get i'll get to that shortly
uh more recently dan dennett
has talked about
consciousness as a user
illusion keith frankish i mentioned
already
michael graziano the psychologist has a
something he calls the attention schema
theory that we have all these schemas
for thinking about the mind self models
that drive us astray
so it's a uh
it's a popular and important view i
don't think though so many illusionists
illusionists have a special motivation
to be interested in the meta problem but
i think i'm not myself an illusionist i
think the meta problem
is interesting even independently of
being an
illusionist i'm you know what
philosophers call a realist about
consciousness we're you know in
philosophy to a first approximation to
be a realist about something is roughly
to believe it's real
so a moral realist is someone who thinks
morality is real a realist about
consciousness thinks consciousness is
real
i think consciousness is not an illusion
i think that solving i don't think that
solving the meta problem suddenly
dissolves
the hard problem
but nonetheless i think the meta problem
is interesting in its own right
i think it's tractable and that solving
it has the potential to at the very
least shed much light on the hard
problem even if it doesn't constitute
a solution in its own right
and i think there's actually a uh
there's actually a research program here
what i'll call the meta problem
research program which i think is a
potentially very productive one it's
open to realists and illusionists alike
to try and solve the meta problem try
and explain these problem reports
it's open to reductionists and
non-reductionists illusionists and
non-illusionists we can try and solve
the meta problem and then think about
the philosophical consequences one
reason why i think this meta problem
program is cool is that it kind of has
it comes with a fairly clear
uh program in both
philosophy
and cognitive science remember the
problem was basically
really we might put this is to explain
certain intuitions we have it's really
to explain certain reports but
maybe some underlying
intuitions or maybe to explain why it's
possible to explain
these uh
these intuitions
um
yeah this this actually brings in i
think in a number of a number of
different areas of cognitive science
really at the core it's a problem the
problem of consciousness you might think
it comes from a philosophical
uh background as the mind-body problem a
problem in metaphysics what is the
nature of the mind the nature of
consciousness but by focusing on the
meta problem this at least carves off a
bit of the problem
that comes with a tractable program in
cognitive science so one thing we want
to do i think first is to distinguish a
bunch of different
problem reports or problem
intuitions that people often display
that lead people to think there's a
there's a that are associated with
there being a problem of consciousness
and i divide these into at least four
groups
there are
metaphysical
intuitions intuitions to the effect that
consciousness seems somehow to be
non-physical
there are explanatory intuitions
tied to this you know this core idea
that consciousness is hard to explain
explaining these objective functions
doesn't explain consciousness
there are knowledge intuitions here the
paradigmatic one would be frank
jackson's classic case of mary
the scientist who was brought up in a
black and white room
knows all the physical facts about color
processing in the brain and wavelengths
and associations
but it seems she doesn't know one really
important thing she doesn't know what
it's like to see red one day she sees a
red rose for the first time
and she learns something new that's the
knowledge
intuition then there are yeah there are
modal intuitions tied to what we can
imagine or conceive what seems possible
so you know various philosophers
including me have argued we can at least
conceive of
zombies
systems
functionally perhaps physically like us
but without consciousness so these are
some of the core
intuitions
in the
associated with the problem of
consciousness there are some others too
maybe slightly less close to the core
there are intuitions about the
distribution of consciousness
maybe that robots are not conscious or
the groups are not conscious for example
intuitions about the value of
consciousness that consciousness matters
morally actually yesterday i was giving
a talk which turned in central part on
that kind of intuition
uh
intuitions about the self that the self
persists through time intuitions about
the qualities presented in consciousness
the special quality you know like the
redness of red
is somehow directly available to me but
i'll concentrate especially on the first
four
now i think yeah one of the cool things
about this
meta problem
project is it comes with a very natural
interdisciplinary research program all
kinds of work is potentially
relevant here there's experimental work
in
both experimental psychology and in
what's called these days experimental
philosophy where you empirically study
people's intuitions about these things
here particularly studying people's
intuitions about consciousness and the
associated
problems
there's also you know building of models
computational models
neurobiological models of intuitions and
reports and there's also a whole lot of
room for philosophical analysis so i
think this you know this meta problem
program is uh just right for
interdisciplinary exploration and it's
been getting a bit of that
in recent years i mean for starters i
mean it's an empirical question how
widely
these intuitions are shared
um
in
a paper i wrote on this uh maybe
four years or so ago now i argued they
were very going to be very widely shared
and you'd expect them to be and
not universal um
some people argue with that and then
actually there actually begun to be some
empirical studies of this my own senses
is that
uh yeah these intuitions
one might expect to be quite widely
shared especially if one's a realist
about consciousness you might think well
the source of these intuitions
is going to be deeply tied to actually
being conscious presumably being
conscious is something that's universal
at least if one's a realist so at least
that source of the intuitions um
should be uh widely shared maybe it
doesn't actually lead to these
intuitions in everybody but you might
think okay at the very least a tendency
in that direction ought to be widely
shared a disposition
to say say these things even if it's
sometimes overridden
by
other things in a
in any given system i mean the
alternative view though is that they're
somehow cultural and local
maybe descartes you know rene descartes
gets blamed for a lot of stuff in the in
philosophy and cognitive science maybe
uh these mind-body intuitions are all
descartes fault i find that very deeply
implausible myself but then
then uh maybe i would given that uh
i have these intuitions very strongly
but but i do think it's this is an
empirical question
um you know traditionally i think in the
last couple of decades of cognitive
science there's been a fair amount of
empirical work on intuitions about the
mind but
network concerns especially i think
belief like
under what conditions uh infants have
the concept of a false belief
uh intuitions about the self like how
how selves persist over time whether
they might continue after death and so
on where consciousness is concerned
perhaps the biggest body of work has
been on distribution of consciousness
um in robots and groups
and so on josh knobe has done some
well-known work about on those questions
where um where problem intuitions are
concerned at least when i wrote this uh
when i first started writing about this
four or five years ago uh there wasn't
so much now there's come to be uh
there's come to at least be a small
literature um experimentally studying
these intuitions and something i wrote i
said the one the intuition i would
expect to be most robust and widespread
is the intuition about mary in the black
and in the black and white room you know
not knowing what it's like to see read
and then learning something just
recently uh daniel gregory and a couple
of other philosophers have published a
very nice experimental study of this
called who knows
what mary knew
and they find that uh
yeah they asked the question did mary
know what it's like to see red when she
had that complete physical knowledge but
had not yet actually experienced
uh the color did mary know what it's
like to see red 82 said no
she didn't but then upon seeing it for
the first time that she then know what
it's like to see red 90 said yes so okay
that's fairly
robust i mean no one expects to get a
hundred percent on any of these things
but uh 80 to 90 percent indicates some
some pretty serious effect
um there are also explanatory
intuitions um
there's a nice paper by sarah gottlieb
and tanya lomboroso doesn't focus just
on consciousness but
focuses on
questions about under what conditions do
people have the intuition that certain
mental phenomena are hard to explain
scientifically
and they find people seem to think that
mental phenomena are especially hard to
explain when they're tied to subjective
experience
and privileged awareness
which at least goes along with the idea
there's some distinctive
explanatory intuitions tied to the hard
problem
you're tied to the hardness of the heart
problem for consciousness more recently
there's an article by rodrigo diaz
called do people think consciousness
poses a hard problem where he's actually
trying to argue that uh these intuitions
are not so
widespread and
well actually there's a lot to say about
this uh this paper which is which is
very interesting it turns out a whole
lot depends on things like you know your
preamble and your you're setting up of
the uh the problem if you set it up with
super like pro science neurobiology
then people say okay yeah science is
doing great if you set it up with a lot
of stuff about uh how consciousness is
so mysterious
not so good with a reasonable reasonably
neutral setup
i think he gets about fifty percent of
people saying consciousness is hard to
explain
fifty percent uh
not so interesting to know um what to
make of this so much to i mean it's hard
to experimentally test a lot of these
things because we have to use words like
explanation which are so ambiguous and
conceivability which has got you know
technical meanings and
and so on so tricky but at least we're
um i think the the literature here at
least is beginning
to develop actually i've done a tiny bit
of empirical work about this
myself i'm not exactly an experimental
philosopher but every now and then i've
taken empirical surveys
of intuitions about philosophy
restricted to the class of professional
philosophers so uh david bourget
and i are independently
we co-developed a website fill papers
which is uh basically a giant
bibliography of philosophy two million
uh two million entries and
it's basically uh turned into a giant
database of philosophy of all kinds and
along the way this involved building a
giant database of email addresses of all
philosophers so we found ourselves back
in 2009 in a position to contact i think
philosophers in 100
departments of philosophy around the
world
and to uh to ask them for their views on
30 key philosophical problems like you
know materialism yes no
other with various uh other options we
did it again in 2020 this time with a
hundred questions and many more
philosophies and that we asked eight
thousand and got
two thousand responses and one of the
questions this time was is there a hard
problem of consciousness and we found 62
percent of philosophers say yes
30 percent say no okay this is a rather
selected and corrupted group that maybe
doesn't uh doesn't reveal a whole lot
about pre-theoretical intuitions because
philosophers have thought about this a
lot still interesting uh interesting
data there was this among scientists
um i don't know of an exact equivalent
of the phil papers survey for
surveying psychologists neuroscientists
ai researchers in general but i don't
know there was one survey
back in 2018 of
attendees at the association for the
scientific study of consciousness
where it's a majority
neuroscientists and psychologists with
again 60 saying some kind of explanatory
gap on explaining functional behavioral
properties
of things that there's a gap to
consciousness again this group is
selected for being interested in
consciousness so by no means like a a
pure sample of pre-theoretical
intuitions but interesting data all the
same there's obviously room for a lot
more um experimental work there so i'm
really trying to encourage this kind of
experimental philosophy and psychology
of
intuitions about
consciousness
i also want to say a bit about potential
solutions to
the problems because you know this idea
of
of explaining the our intuitions has
been around for a while
there are at least some kind of
quasi-standard
approaches here i mean this literature
is extremely
fragmented um i think at least until
recently there was just a proposal here
and a proposal there that didn't really
make contact with each other but i think
it's possible to
systematize them and i've tried to do
this
a little bit by looking at a few
different
uh factors that might be generating
these intuitions about consciousness and
again
these moves are available equally to the
illusionist who thinks it's all an
illusion and the realist who thinks all
this is uh
is real one key very basic idea
uh
dark hofstadter i think is argued for
for this kind of view at some length and
uh more recently michael graziano's
theory is a version of this basically
says it coming it all comes down to
certain internal self models we all have
models
of ourselves in particular models of our
own
cognitive processes and these models can
greatly distort the real thing sometimes
they greatly simplify the real thing
sometimes they add to the real thing
they needn't
exactly resemble they didn't represent
the real thing perfectly but these
introspective models will somehow
explain
our sense that we're conscious
and that there's a problem of
consciousness and that much i find quite
plausible but now the question is how
what kind of introspective models
are going to uh to do this
well here's a
escher print that hofstadter uses to
somehow explain the idea that our wonky
self-models somehow lead to the
existence of the problem represented by
the big hole at the center where nothing
makes sense
um a related idea is this idea
often associated with david armstrong
of introspective opacity here the key
idea is well we don't see
that consciousness is physical
introspection is opaque as to the
underlying mechanisms it doesn't show us
the underlying mechanisms of
consciousness we don't see the
consciousnesses physicals and then we go
on to infer we're going to see it as
non-physical and this is meant to have
some
analogs with this uh this circus
illusion of you know the headless person
we don't see their head
so we see them as having
no head here's a picture of uh
you know the so-called
headless woman illusion which was i
guess popular in 19th century
circuses and there's just you know
there's someone sitting there with their
head behind the screen and i guess the
idea is under the right conditions at
least for a moment this is like oh my
god that person has no head
um i don't know how we how much the
perceptual system really gets taken in
by this but um
maybe there are circumstances where it
looks a little bit like that i certainly
do i mean i do think i mean you take
special circumstances to get this going
i mean i can block out the heads of a
few of you and it doesn't suddenly look
like there's a bunch of headless people
in the uh
in the audience um so i think you only
actually make this inference under
certain very special
under certain very special conditions i
think that itself uh needs
explaining there's also further
questions like you know why doesn't
introspection of say belief and other
mental states generate the same gap
indeed
even for our awareness of say of
computers and algorithms i know my
iphone is running some kind of some kind
of computation under the surface when i
use this but i've got no idea i mean for
most of us it's totally you know who
knows what's going on there i guess it's
some kind of some kind of silicon
circuits but
you know we've got no awareness of that
we've got no awareness of the physical
processes
underneath
underneath all this but doesn't mean
that we suddenly have some sense that
it's non-physical so i think this
explanation
overgeneralizes even though there may be
something to it
um one idea is that color experience and
other kind of experiences may attribute
certain kinds of primitive
qualities to objects so usually there's
red that red exit sign
and so on what's actually going on in
nature as some very complex reflectance
property out there but we model it as
this very simple
primitive feature of you know redness
in uh in the world it's primitive
quality instantiated out there in the
world and that makes maybe for some very
simple model of things in the world is
having these different
primitive colors likewise for yellow
and the like um
in some other work i've
thought of this as like model modeling
the external world as a kind of a garden
of eden with all these primitive
qualities exactly as they appear
in to us in perception and that though
that edenic world could at least serve
as a useful model of the complex
world that we live in so maybe then the
thought is maybe something like that's
going on in the mind maybe to model the
mind we also attribute primitive
qualities to the mind the same way we
attribute primitive qualities
to the world um i'm not sure yet that
gets at the key issue though which is
tied to our experience or our
awareness
of qualities and i think to get to that
you really need to go beyond this too
well a sense of being related to these
qualities in the world of being aware of
them and maybe in particular our
internal models
give us a sense of being acquainted both
with concrete qualities and with our
awareness of them
which i think is i think this is uh
this i think is getting closer to the
heart of the matter but as with all
these explanations it always just keeps
pushing back the question a bit for me
okay but how and why
does that work
so if i if i was trying to put all this
together into a summary here's like my
you know my summary of one possible
approach or potential beginning of a
solution sketch to the metal problem why
do we make
uh
why do we have this sense there's a
problem of consciousness
one thing i like by the way about this
kind of summary is you can either
realize this read this in a realist tone
of voice
about from the point of view someone
thinks consciousness is real and these
are the mechanisms or in a illusionist
tone of voice where this is an account
of the illusion i think the kind of
explanation i'm giving here is neutral
on that you just say okay we have
introspective models
deploying introspective concepts of our
internal states that are largely
independent of our physical concepts
these concepts are introspectively
opaque not revealing any of the
underlying mechanisms
our perceptual models perceptually
attribute primitive perceptual qualities
to the world
and our introspective models attribute
primitive mental relations to these
qualities
these models produce the sense of
acquaintance both with those qualities
and with our awareness of those
qualities i guess i'm inclined to find
something like this
somewhat plausible as an account of
what's going into uh
the intuitions at the same time it feels
to be more like less like an explanation
of the intuitions and more like a kind
of a fleshing out of what the intuitions
are what i'd really like to see is some
kind of story of maybe some kind of
algorithmic basis
uh for the intuitions where things went
this way and where you know if you
actually built that algorithm you would
see it displaying
the relevant intuitions i mean one way
we can test
solutions to the meta problem is by you
know trying to formulate them maybe in
some kind of algorithmic terms test
those explanations with psychological
studies and computational
models i mean the only thing in this
direction i really know so far is
something by luke mulhauser and buck
schlageris where
they took some fairly simple ideas about
the meta problem that
uh that the philosopher francois camera
and i
had put forward and they tried to build
in those ideas into a little little
software agent which they gave a bunch
of axioms and the ability to derive
conclusions from those axioms and a few
basic principles about consciousnesses
the axioms and they actually found it
produced little theorems the reports
like yeah consciousness my experience
i've read distinct from any brain
process
and
and so okay which is promising and
interesting although um
you know i think it's very much a toy
model and they they do build a fair
quite a lot uh into this model um
interesting question if a machine issues
the same sort of problem reports as us
and caused by similar mechanisms that we
think are present in us should we take
that actually as evidence that the
machine is conscious
here a few people have suggested that
you could actually potentially use
problem reports as a sort of turing test
for machine consciousness aaron sloman
susan schneider ed turner have said you
know one way to test whether a machine
is conscious is to see whether it is
puzzled about consciousness if it says
you know
well
i know i'm just a bunch of
silicon chips but i feel subjectively
like so much more
then is that some kind of sign that it
might actually be uh be conscious on the
other hand you know you might say the
machine might say damn where do i need
to go why do i need to be
uh so theoretically confused as those
damn as those damn humans it's like in
the regular turing test the poor machine
has to drag itself down to talk like a
dumb human being uh here's the poor sad
machine
studying the talk like a human test book
test preparation book likewise for the
meta problem it's like okay why do i
really need to have confused intuitions
about consciousness
as the humans did do but um if it did
display those intuitions though maybe
that would be some
evidence
um
i was going to say something about
impact on theories of consciousness
although maybe i think i'll i'll skip
over this for uh for reasons of time
here the ideas from a realist
perspective a solution to the meta
problem and a solution to the hard
problem might be closely connected and
we could use this as a kind of test for
theories of consciousness see whatever
explains consciousness should also
partly explain our judgments about
consciousness
and here the ideas would be strange if
the basis of consciousness played no
role at all in judgments
about consciousness and i here i go on
to argue that
some theories of consciousness
you know don't seem to pass this test
that the mechanisms of consciousness
explain
the judgments
about consciousness i mean i argue for
example that to no needs integrated
information theory has trouble meeting
this uh meeting this challenge but maybe
i'll skip over that for reasons of time
so just to conclude i'll and just by
saying something a little bit about this
underlying issue between the realist and
the illusionist about consciousness i
mean the illusionist says consciousness
doesn't exist we just think it does a
solution to the meta problem dissolves
the hard problem
um strong illusionism says phenomenal
consciousness does not exist at all
um you know this is a very attractively
austere view
of of consciousness you know its main
problem is it seems somehow um
impossible to believe here's one way to
put the argument against it as a
just a flat foot of arguments like
people sometimes feel pain
if strong illusionism is true no one
feels pain
therefore uh strong illusionism is false
so here's the underlying ideas well it's
just a datum that we have certain kinds
of conscious experiences like feeling
pain
experiencing red you might put this uh
in some neutral form it's like well it's
unbelievable it's just impossible to
believe illusionism because it's somehow
unbelievable that no one feels pain
and that no one is conscious so
illusionism is unbelievable now the
illusionist does themselves have an
interesting reply here which is
uh my view predicts that my view is
is unbelievable um you know it's just
those models you have in your brain that
makes it forces you to think you're
conscious and
and the consciousness can't be an
illusion but it might still
be uh be wrong
um so just to conclude then
one way of putting this kind of
illusionist
realist
showdown is between two different forms
of absurdity two different kinds of
claims about absurdity here's the
philosopher galen strawson saying
illusionism is absurd
there occurred in the 20th century the
most remarkable episode of the whole
history of ideas
a number of thinkers denied the
existence of something we know with
certainty to exist namely consciousness
okay it's the most absurd thing he's
ever heard here on the other side is the
uh the rationalist philosopher eliezer
yudkowski
arguing that
epiphenomenalism is um absurd and here
he was this was something he wrote
engaging with some of my ideas in my
book the conscious mind where i talked
about zombies he says the zombie
argument may be a candidate for the most
deranged idea
in all of philosophy the causally closed
cognitive system of chalmers internal
narrative is malfunctioning in a way
that not by necessity but just in our
universe miraculously happens to be
correct and here this is getting an
interesting idea which is if you're a
realist about consciousness maybe not
just an epi phenomenalist but a realist
more generally somehow it looks like you
can explain all those things we say
without mentioning consciousness so
somehow the fact that the things we say
are actually true ends up being kind of
a remarkable coincidence
so realism ends up being absurd
too there is middle ground here of
course between those extreme views i
think it tends to slide back to the same
problems
other forms of illusionism don't help
with the hard problem
other forms of realism are still subject
to the miraculous correctness or the
idea that merely true by
coincidence so i think to get beyond
you know absurdity here there's
challenges
for both sides the illusionist needs to
explain
how having a mind can be somehow like
this
even if it's not the way if it's not
completely the way that it seems
the realist needs to explain to avoid
this coincidence worry the realist needs
to explain how meta problem processes
are essentially grounded in
consciousness
even if it's possible for them to occur
without
consciousness
but either way i think i mean if we can
get a solution to the meta problem that
meets these ambitions that may just
possibly lead to a solution to the hard
problem
of consciousness in the meantime i think
the meta problem is a potentially
tractable research project for everyone
thank you
[Applause]
10 to 15 minutes for questions for
professor chalmers after which he will
be visiting the metaphysics meets
cognitive science course
who has some questions about
consciousness
who has some meta questions
anyone anyone
i'll start things off
in your slide um where you kind of
summarize the view that you were
developing
um i actually just had a question about
the interpretation of that text and so i
wanted to ask you about that thanks for
going back to that
yes so
um
so you say our perceptual models
perceptually attribute primitive
perceptual qualities to the world
and i just didn't understand that phrase
this is a legitimate and just if you
could say a little bit more about what
you mean by perceptual attribution
um and uh
primitive perceptual qualities and then
i actually then and i had a secondary
question which is i don't really know
what you mean by the sense of
acquaintance so i'm just wondering if
you could elaborate on that a little bit
okay so the perceptual models
and the primitive perceptual qualities
was meant to be a version of
yeah this thing the uh i like the the
intuitions grounded in color experience
somehow
yeah in perceptions like redness just
seems to be this kind of this primitive
quality of objects that redness is kind
of spread out over the exit sign it
seems to be this you know this very
distinctive shiny
quality
out there as far as perception is
concerned it seems to be basically a
primitive thing there's red and there's
um and there's green and maybe there's a
mountainous of
there's amounts of redness and amounts
of blueness that we can decompose
phenomenologically but it certainly
doesn't seem to be a complex
property or a reducible property so many
people have made this point about the
phenomenology of color
that in seeing a color we seem to be the
world seems to be populated by these
these special primitive qualities i
think you know something similar might
go for for pitch you can argue about
space uh but at least for uh for color
um are you are you uncomfortable with uh
with that much
i mean part of what i was in
i mean there's also
say the way that brian would describe
perception and it would be a little bit
different
yeah so this is very much from the
phenomenological
perspective this is how this is kind of
how perception seems it seems to
attribute these primitive qualities
to things in the
i mean i find it world difficult to try
to talk about this in a way that it's
like i get it intuitively but then how
to express it in language it's very
important so what do you mean what is it
what is it here and what does it do
yeah it's a good question i mean i think
the basic idea is we seem to stand in a
particularly direct epistemological
relation to these properties both the
properties in the world the redness
out there i think phenomenologically it
seems that there's some redness out
there and it seems that i'm in very
direct
contact
with it i mean exactly what nature that
contact has is you know you can argue
about that but you know people have the
catapult theories and the intermission
theories and i don't know um
but uh but also i think even more when
it comes to consciousness itself to my
you know my awareness of that that
redness my experience there's this idea
that we have some kind of direct
acquaintance with uh
with what it's like to be us maybe more
primitive than any conceptual grasp it's
just those properties are somehow
phenomenologically it feels like you
know phenomenal properties are just
there for us when mary sees red for the
first time she becomes acquainted with a
certain kind of experience that she
hadn't had before now maybe that
intuition is wrong but i think it it is
a i don't know that it's a direct
phenomenological
uh
intuition i mean acquaintance is kind of
a technical term this is already getting
a little bit theoretical so think about
maybe more or something which just lies
behind
some of our more surface intuitions as a
potentially unifying
explainer of them
the sense of acquaintance
um
yeah i know you yourself
hello
um i know you're not an illusionist
yourself but i kind of wanted to clarify
that idea
um normally with skepticism
there's kind of this gap between what is
and what we perceive so if i'm a skeptic
you know i perceive a table here but how
do i know that there actually is a table
if there's nothing
with illusionism how can there be a gap
between
kind of what we think we think and what
we think
um to me like i'm kind of on the this is
absurd camp and i think there's probably
a more charitable explanation
yeah i mean
certainly many people have accused the
view of being a uh
being somehow contradictory or self
undermining i think one way to put it is
here yeah the strong illusionism is
contradictory because you might think
that the illusion itself to undergo an
illusion is itself a kind of conscious
experience
so you're saying you're conscious
yeah well you're not actually conscious
you're merely
you merely have the illusion of
consciousness we understood that as
requiring the conscious experience that
you are conscious then that would seem
to be
contradictory so i think the illusionist
had better understand illusions here is
something that doesn't require
consciousness i mean maybe it could be
something analogous to say unconscious
perception but maybe one another way to
think about it is this is something that
goes on at the level of judgment
we've got uh yeah things we perceive to
be the case and things we judge to be
the case and yeah maybe on some views
judgment um is
a conscious act or very often a
conscious act but i think the thought is
we could there is a version there's an
analog of judgment a kind of mental act
of taking something to be the case that
needn't actually be conscious so maybe
think of this as a non-conscious
judgment
that we are conscious and you know even
maybe an ai system think about an ai
system that goes around building these
weird representations of itself as
having these special properties no one's
inclined to say the ai system is
conscious but it seems to at the very
least be producing the reports
that they're conscious i mean at the
very least think of the judgment as a
disposition to report
then at least we've escaped the charge
hopefully of contradiction
does that help
yeah
thank you just a also a purely
clarifying question i will
can you say a little bit more about what
the coincidence is that all realist and
not only epi phenomenalist are meant to
have to explain
i didn't really understand what the
accusation is from the illusion inside
the sorry the uh this was about
acquaintance sorry the coincidence
coincidence oh yeah you're right i
didn't really say nearly enough
about that the i think here's one idea
just say there's an algorithmic
explanation
of why we say the things we say about
consciousness
but there's no algorithmic explanation
of consciousness consciousness is
something super algorithmic as many
realists think then you think well
that's at least an uncomfortable
explanation because it starts to look as
if what
our judgments about consciousness are
made almost independently of
consciousness itself and then you go on
to say well but actually there are these
properties of consciousness over and
above the algorithm
and the algorithm is getting them right
you know when it says yeah i'm having
that red experience i'm having
experienced a structured a certain way
that's all going on and it starts to
look like boy
it's really lucky
that uh you know that we actually got
these things right because it looks like
well that algorithm could have gone
without consciousness it could have gone
on with different consciousness maybe
the psychophysical laws
the laws connecting algorithms and
consciousness and such that at least
most of the time that's going to be
right but even then it starts to look
like boy lucky that we live in a world
where the psychophysical laws
connect up the algorithms to
consciousness
that way so i get something like that as
a thought i don't intend it to be
conclusive i think there are lots of
things to say in reply and i've heard
people say interesting things in reply
but i don't feel that's for me that's
that's perhaps the most actually the
most forceful
objection to to realism about
consciousness
hi um
i noticed that you said something about
how the problem reports are kind of
evidence or it seemed like you were
implying that they're kind of evidence
not only that consciousness exists but
also that it has a tangible noticeable
effect on the world that we perceive
and i was wondering what are your
thoughts on like
arguments about
how um evolutionary function
could uh
like why would it beneficial for an
organism to evolve to not only present
the information that it experiences to
the conscious processes of the if
consciousness is a physical process why
would it present it to that in an
organized way and then why would it
listen for a response from the conscious
process and then allow that to affect
the world in an organized way so what
would be the evolutionary benefit of
like why would it be beneficial for an
organism to evolve
so that uh it not only like responds to
phenomena outside but it also delivers
it to this mysterious consciousness
phenomenon and then listens i'm not so
much just asking this question i'm just
asking like
what do you think of those arguments do
you think that they hold water do you
think they're limited in some way i
don't have any good story to tell about
the evolutionary benefits of
consciousness itself this is one of the
deepest mysteries
in the field
anything you might posit we need
consciousness for that looks like in
principle
it's hard to see why you couldn't do
that without consciousness on the other
hand where the meta problem is concerned
maybe there's something interesting we
can say about why there are evolutionary
benefits in having a model of
consciousness
that attributes these special properties
of consciousness to you i mean i think
of this
just say with the color case why might
it be
useful to have perceptual
perception some kind of model of colors
as these primitive things
in the world
maybe which in the model and the model's
got doesn't build in these complex
reflectance properties that exist in
reality well we don't need all that
complexity just to make these
distinctions it just turns out well it's
really useful
to uh to be able to you know distinguish
certain kinds of you know fruits from uh
from others and certain kinds of
physical objects from others and these
are attributing these primitive
qualities is just a really good way to
do them likewise when it comes to i mean
you can easily tell a story about why
it's useful for us to have a model of
our own mind
um and to have a model indeed of other
people's minds
and then at least with a bit of hand
waving you can tell some story about why
it might actually be useful to uh
say oh whenever instead of saying we've
got these really complex causal
representational relations to things in
the world it's like no we have this
simple relation of consciousness
uh to those
to those qualities now i don't have a
detailed version of that story
people like graziano and nick humphrey
have tried to sketch versions of stories
like that
i think there's at least an interesting
research program there of looking at the
benefits of self models with certain
with certain properties that may be for
example socially useful and dealing with
other people
um you know we have to communicate our
states of mind with each other having a
kind of yeah maybe maybe certain kinds
of self-models involving models of
consciousness can help
um i was wondering if you differentiate
between
uh
consciousness related and consciousness
independent sources of problem
intuitions
i was reading the paper that talked
about that and i was confused about how
any of these intuitions
that presumably come from our conscious
mind could be truly independent of
consciousness
yeah
i think what i actually say in the paper
is i want them to be uh
topic neutral because i don't want these
explanations to mention consciousness
anywhere if they mention consciousness
then they're no longer going to be
neutral between the illusionist and
the realist but i do think it's true
that at least a realist is going to look
at some of the things i say here and say
all those things are consequences of
consciousness
why do we have these introspective
models deploying introspective concepts
because we're conscious
um and you know we're acquainted with
consciousness whatever and that's what
actually gives us the models and the
concepts why do we pers why do our
models perceptually attribute these
qualities because they really are
these qualities at least in the mind we
really are acquainted with consciousness
so i think that's a realist can say
that this topic neutral explanation is
in fact dependent on consciousness on
the other hand the illusionist i think
can
endorse
hopefully endorse this without actual
well without saying any of it is
dependent on consciousness so we somehow
come to have these introspective models
without consciousness we have this sense
of acquaintance without consciousness
but somehow that gives us the sense
um that we're conscious so i guess yeah
the rules
the rule is not that this has to be
consciousness independent in the sense
that it's not actually grounded in
conscious consciousness but maybe it's
meant to be at least an explanation that
one can grasp
without uh without it somehow
immediately entailing
or requiring the existence of
consciousness if that makes sense but
yeah there's probably a few different
notions of consciousness dependence here
that i could probably be more careful
about separating
before david has to head upstairs to
so i have a question about emergentism
uh in the study of complex systems for
example neuroscience one of the common
theme is that
you can never you can never explain the
property of complex collective systems
from the single constituents for example
memory and learning those complex
functions can only emerge from the
complex interaction or dynamics between
the groups so i would
so i would ask do you think
the way mary sees color is one of those
emerging properties that cannot be
explained by the simple
simple materials
yeah
i think it is fairly plausible that
consciousness emerges
from
brain processes
somehow but i think this word emergence
kind of covers up a variety of
of sins you know it's like
sometimes i say it's like it's a kind of
it's like a magic word that people use
to make them feel better about things
they don't understand it's like you know
the key question is how does it emerge
and and why
philosophers sometimes distinguish
strong emergence from weak emergence
strong emergence involves something
fundamentally new
weak emergence is more like what you get
say in non-linear systems
you know the game of life it follows a
few very simple rules at the bottom
level and at the higher level so some
really surprising things
happen but in those cases it looks like
the surprising things they're surprising
but they're not too surprising in the
sense that if you actually work through
the lower level processes carefully you
can tell some pretty straightforward
story about how it is that all those
rules come together and they'll generate
the high level phenomena say if i don't
know life or of
behavior of complex cellular
entities so that's weak emergence
and in those cases actually but what
needed explaining was still something
much closer to the easy problems you
know some complicated functional things
that a system does and yeah surprisingly
some simple mechanisms
can do that nothing like that seems to
work i think for a consciousness it
doesn't seem to just be a matter of oh
my god it's somewhat surprising but in
principle if you work through it enough
you can see how this would uh
this would uh this would come out i mean
the gap seems of a somewhat different
character here
uh
you know it just seems like a different
kind of thing you're trying to explain
not one of those objective functions and
because of that you know the gap seems
to be much more principled and that this
leads to it being a case of what
philosophers call strong emergence
and yeah if it's strong emergence then
the question is well now it's something
fundamentally new maybe involving
fundamentally new properties in nature
now it starts to look like a version of
what philosophers call
property dualism
which i think is okay and that's also a
possibility but insofar as many people
want to use emergence to kind of support
a materialist view come on it's just
another emergent property like uh
like uh like life or
like the weather
um
i think that will only work if it's weak
emergence not uh yeah if that's meant to
support a materialist reduction that
will only work if it's weak emergence
but i think that's less plausible in the
case of consciousness
okay everybody we are in an awkward
position now because we have already
applauded for these excellent ideas that
david has shared with us and it would be
sort of weird to just do that again so
let us go meta and applaud david for
handling the questions and the
organization of these ideas
i applaud your applause
[Applause]